so there's a second before you you
recognize something obviously he's
pushing that way so I'm going to let it
push me I do it with a mixture of a
rotation I did with a mixture of a
weight shift due to a mixture of
synchronize and her sequencing my corner
movement my chosen hip movement so oh I
think I make it very soft so I think
he's he's not really pushing on anything
so I try to let's say his force is 10
I'm trying to give him a space of 10 so
he's not really pushing it on anything
and then he will fall into that hole and
I'm not pushing that's the drill so whoa
he'll fall into the hole my drill is to
make a space of 10 for his force of 10
pull if you pay attention to my arm
you'll see how relaxed it is okay but
it's not this
nothing's going to imagine really happen
because you relax like you're going to
sleep so even as I'm doing this look at
it tactically look at the check on his
shoulder you see when you guys just
relax you having to check on his
shoulder look at the tilt on his spine
see when you're doing it you have no
tilt on this part so go slow so if I'm
doing it right you're going to get the
cross lateral check on this shoulder
you're gonna get the tilt on his spine
and now this is just dropping that's
where he's going to want to fall that's
different from this it is also different
from this I want to establish the zero
point so you can see how light I did
okay try it so even if he's standing
still there's still a force to it right
there's still a force to it it I'll have
to be able to find so I moved more
forward did you see right now his
gravitational pull has a force oh okay I
have to keep you grip I have to
neutralize it
so he's coming in he's gonna keep his
grip straighten your spine when you roll
[Music]
so you have to move out because of the
weight that's come in is and if you are
not pushed over by that weight because
you moved out of this range then your
penetration range is not there do you
understand that so again way what you
are doing so if the arm is fine but they
weigh right here so that you don't feel
the weight this weight that way so you
go to here yeah I don't feel it then I
can't get so yes I'm going to give him
his X void but it's also why does my
hand keep coming back here
no he keeps moving that way so I keep
letting it right and what's pushing it
his body so when we say a 10 Boyd or an
ex boy it can't just be on the arm and
then you this thing's moving towards you
you see this this grip is nothing more
than that Center everything comes back
to the center wherever it is matches
wherever I get the maximum reading of
his force that's where I decide to see
and that's why I move because I've
neutralized his maxim here's where you
stop and then oh man or your solution
out here then nothing so let him keep
pushing you oh then you can assist that
by going under it you see how it's
coming this way
so Jonathan I'm going to go under it not
pushing him right down on that foot you
see that I need that foot to be a
fulcrum towards the rotation so I have
to be under it
I'll do anything for me your job that's
all you have to do is straight forth
that's it
I don't have cooking fingers on
ballistics right so then there's no
transference from my grad training you
might writing training what we were
supposed to do was not pull on the hat
but to find where I'm gonna match with
void his oncoming force well that's what
I'm doing here so when I go like this
you're doesn't work so I'm gonna feel
all I felt that I feel it I'll let it go
around I'm waiting for it to get there
there it is you see I feel it let it go
round like doing it Vinci I'm on one
side than the other
it is very important that your kid
doesn't go like this you see I was the
one who minute he has to just his
initial action that's what I'm feeling
then then I'm gonna add to it by tilting
him you see so I'm effecting this
balance
don't do anything